hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the tarash
defense which is
a variation in the queen's gambit
decline lines queen's game it starts out
with
d4 d5 and then c
4 followed by e6 this is the queen's
game of decline and then
knight c3 pawn two c5 this is the trash
defense it's a pretty aggressive line
from black to counter
the center control of the board the
specific lines we're going to be going
over today the first
is the main variation that is the pawn
taking here on
d5 we're also going to look at knight to
f3
as well as just e3 solidifying the pawn
chain here from
white so the first variation the main
line
is the pawn taking here on d5 black's
always gonna capture
on d5 and this is nice from black
because it opens up
both of the bishops many times when
black opens especially
in the queen's game of decline lines
it's very difficult to get both of the
bishops
involved into the game but you can see
already the star square bishop
can get outside the pawn chain as well
as the slight square bishop as well
white has two responses one's gonna be
to take this pawn here on
c5 the other one is just gonna play
knight two f3
development move controlling the center
of the board protecting this pawn here
on d4 so the first one we're gonna look
at is if the pawn takes on
c5 there's a lot of ways that black can
respond here
we have just pushing forward with d4
attacking this knight right here the
bishop taking here on
c5 as well as just playing knight to f6
protecting this pawn here on
d5 i'm gonna go over all three options
but i do recommend
playing the pawn pushing forward here to
d4 i think this is if you have an
isolated queen pawn
i think pushing it up the board and
putting pressure on your opponent is the
best way to go about it
if you have an isolated queen pond and
you just allow your opponent to
aim all of their material at that it
really creates a weakness for you so i
use
i like to take that opportunity and flip
it on his head and really attack my
opponent with that so attacking the
knight here on
c3 they have a couple options they could
look at it and say queen to
a4 check and i'm just going to go ahead
and take this material here on d4
that's not going to work though because
knight 2 c6
this not only stops the check but also
protects this pawn here on
d4 now they could even come down to
knight to b5
attacking this pawn on d4 but then we
play bishop takes on
c5 and we have the knight the bishop and
the queen all protecting
uh this pawn so queen to a4 is not going
to work for them they could also play
uh knight e4 since their knights under
attack really need to be moving that
knights here
in this case we are going to play knight
to f6
attacking the knight now they could go
ahead and take our our knight here
that's fine we do want to capture with
our queen here i don't want to blow up
our king
side protection of the pawns um and
from here maybe they play pawn to b4
we played knight to c6 attacking this
pawn right here
completely exposing their queen side of
the board is pushing up their their
pawns here have no queen protection
don't have their light square bishop
involved into the game
because their e pawn has not moved as
well if they continue pushing
you know we can just counter with
something like a5 and really blow things
up but we do
have both of our bishops involved into
the game we have our queen involved into
the game
we have this pawn here although it's an
isolated queen pawn it's putting a lot
of pressure on
many of the squares white would want to
go to and we do have a
knights here on c6 they can easily get
involved into the game as well
sometimes they don't take that knight
tier on f6 a lot of players anytime they
see knights come to f6 they immediately
play
bishop to g5 this pins down the knight
to the queen it also allows them to play
something like
e3 while getting their dark square
bishop involved into the game before it
gets blocked off by something like
e3 in this case we're just going to play
knight to c6 this adds another defender
to this pawn here on
d4 which is definitely what we're
looking for
the reason i prefer the move d4
after they take the pawn here on at c5
is because i think if let's say bishop
takes here on
c5 which hey black got that material
back
both sides two pawns down in material
black has both the bishops involved into
the game
but things get pretty tricky if they
play queen takes here on
d5 yes we could just take with our queen
but if they take here then they're
threatening this knight to
c7 check forking the rook here and you
can see
whites up a pawn and material without
our queen we're really left in a tough
spot now we do
have the move queen to b6 and this is
threatening
this bishop coming and taking here on f2
if you think your opponent
may not play optimally here then this
could be an option for
for sure because they could play a
mistake they could play something
like queen two e5 check and we played
knight to e7
and it's pretty enticing for them to
take this pawn here on g7
and they're like okay what's the big
deal here i'm gonna go ahead and attack
this rook but
we do have to move bishop to f2 check
king comes to
d1 now rook to g8 maybe they try to
gobble up more material
queen 2 h7 yes our king is completely in
the center of the board
but after bishop to f5 attacking this
queen here our rook is protected by the
knight
this queen right here on b6 is
protecting the bishop you can see
their king is exposed as well we can
start to have
a lot of attacks on board and white's
gonna have a pretty tough spot
in this example but if they don't play
queen to e5 and try to give a check if
they just play the move
knight to e4 this defends the pawn here
on f2
and now black really doesn't have a
strong attack so i think
this move here on e4 stops it for me as
far as actually wanting to play that
bishop taking here on
c5 right away now the other option
is black has the option of pawn taking
here on
c5 and then knight to f6
they could just defend this pawn right
here maybe b4
we played knight to c6 and they have a
couple options here they could defend
with pawn to a3 protecting this pawn
right here
and then we just push forward attack
their knight here i
always recommend using that isolated
queen pawn to attack
uh maybe knight to a4 pawn up here b5
attacking the knight they could open
and take the pawn but that's fine we
play pawn
takes here on b6 the rook is attacking
the knight here on a4
that on a4 is just awkwardly placed and
we still have both of our bishops can
easily get involved into the game
black should be okay in the spot and
also if
if we instead don't say a3 they could
just push forward
with b5 that's fine we're still going to
push forward here with d4 attacking
maybe they come a4 we play knight to e4
things can get pretty tricky here with
queen 2a5 check
and after the queen takes we can gobble
up that material as well so
as far as my rank i think d4 is probably
my favorite followed by
knight to f6 and then
followed by bishop taking here on
c5 as far as how i would respond if they
take this but they don't have to take
here on
c5 they could also just play knight to
f3
if that's the case we're just going to
play knight to f6 said it before
many times you play knight to f6 they
are immediately going to play
bishop here to g5 we're going to play
knight to c6
the key difference here is if they play
bishop takes on f6
we don't want to take with our queen
before i said yes you do want to take
this is a situation
you don't because they can now just play
knight takes here on
d5 attacking the queen right here also
threatening the knight coming down here
to
c7 so in this instance with this
specific setup
uh the bishop takes here i do recommend
taking with your
pawn right here now we come back maybe
they don't play bishop here to
g5 uh many times players like to
fianchetto on the king side of the board
i've seen in this uh terrace defense so
maybe
g3 and we're still going to play knight
to c6 here
bishop here g2 and then we take with our
pawn here on
d4 they take with their knight and then
we play bishop here to
c5 attacking the knight also threatening
behind that the f2
weakened square we can castle on the
king side
and now you can see both sides are equal
in material but black has a pretty good
setup
also opened up for the light square
bishop to get involved into the game
uh so things pretty good if they decide
to go the knight to f3 route
the next variation is what if they don't
take here on d5 what if they
instead play knight to f3 just simple
development move
for the knights here we're going to go
ahead and take with our pawn on d4
anytime we we play up here to c5 we are
attacking the center
of the board and if they're not going to
take their pawn we are definitely going
to capture
their center now they have two options
they could take with their knight they
could take with their queen
knight team's more reasonable to me
we're just going to play knight to
f6 here any time they play this
uh they they could just take with their
pawn we're just gonna take with our
knights right here
if they take we do have the isolated
queen pawn that's completely fine
uh many times instead of taking they
could just play the bishop to g5 as
we've talked about before
we're just going to go ahead and take
that material here on c4 now black
is up in material we've only given up
one pawn black white's given up two
which is pretty rare in the trash
defense because usually white has an
extra pawn but black has more
developments can get their bishops
involved into the game it can put a lot
of pressure
with their isolated queen pawn on the
opponent but in this case you can see
black is now up in material and if they
take then we can take with our queen we
don't have to destroy our king inside
the board
because they don't have any threats of
taking extra material now
if we come back and say what if they
don't take with their knights if they
take with their queen i think this is
pretty poor
because any time the queen here on d4 we
could just play knight two c6
attacking this queen they could play
something you know queen to h4
we exchange but after the exchange right
here we tape
take on c4 black is up in material and
white's just awkwardly placed the knight
here on h4 is not doing
much good at all they could also play
their queen somewhere else queen 2h
g4 you never know exactly where they're
going to go here but this gets tricky
with pawn to
d4 and where exactly do they go you know
coming back to b1 feels pretty bad
they're just losing
so much in development that's that's two
moves that they brought it out here to
c3 and then moving it back here
uh e4 doesn't work because of f5
this forks the queen and the knight here
that's not good
they maybe look at knight to b5 and say
okay now i have two knights and a queen
all attacking this pawn maybe that feels
good because now black is overloaded
because it only has two pieces but now
we can just play pawn to a3 and said go
ahead and take that pawn that's fine
with us because after they do we can now
play bishop here to b4
and after bishop takes our bishop to d2
and we
capture here now knight takes on d2 and
this is where we've removed one of the
defenders so the knights here
on f3 was defending the square so after
knight takes on d2 we can now come up
with queen to
d4 and we're in a pretty good spot
the last version we are going to look at
is if they play pawn to e3
a lot of players if they see a very
aggressive move like the trash defense
is
they get pretty defensive and pawn to e3
does exactly
that it solidifies the pawn chain so if
we do capture here
then they can just recapture and so
it allows them to play pretty safely
now if they do play that e3 we're just
going to play knight
to f6 here and now if they decide to
capture
that's completely fine it's going to
look very similar to some of the other
variations that we've looked at
if they just don't want to take a
material at all that's just not in their
game plan that's part of the reason they
play e3
let's say they play knight to f3 we're
gonna play knight to c6 here
maybe they play bishop to d3 and this is
one of those instances anytime you see
bishop coming here to d3 and you have a
pawn that can
capture in the queen's gambit you
usually want to capture that material
because they're going to be
capturing with their bishop they've
essentially lost a move they brought
their bishop here to d3
now we're forcing them to move that
bishop here to
c4 so did lose a move we're going to
capture here on
d4 they recapture and then bishop here
to
d6 and you can see pretty good setup and
now we
have white with the queen isolated pawn
so we can start to
attack that go ahead and castle on the
king side get some safety here
but then yeah black's game plane is
going to be attack this isolated pawn
right here
and black should have a good game so
that is the terrace defense
it's always good to have different moves
against the queen's gambit since it is
such a popular
opening uh but hopefully you guys
enjoyed this one if there's other videos
you'd like me to make let me know in the
comments below or you can always email
me at thechess website at gmail.com
but thank you guys so much for watching
and i will see you in the next video